a presumption among many thoughtful
people is that the great enemy of a good
life and a decent world is something
called bias by bias people have come to
understand a twisting of the facts
towards dark and entirely negative ends
according to this interpretation bias is
invariably and necessarily bad in some
quarters the word has simply grown
synonymous with evil in order to hate
bias so much one has to love the idea of
something else with equal passion the
facts people hate bias because they
ultimately believe in the redemptive
possibility of something completely
objective and scientifically verifiable
loathing of bias is the flipside of love
of facts science and many of the human
sciences are beautifully founded on
evidence-based fact yielding work the
problem is that in many of the most
important aspects of existence there
simply are no facts available the big
questions that bedevils individually and
collectively have no facts to appeal to
how should we live what's the right
economic system to institute what sort
of relationship should we have what
kinds of choices should we make who are
we and what do we want and need
in the face of such dilemmas we may well
long for facts by which we really mean
answers that we can be assured will be
indisputably correct but we invariably
face ambiguity and whatever answers we
formulate a degree of loss and the risk
of blindness and error its these
elements which the haters of bias are
deep down especially intolerant towards
and upset about the hatred of bias
reflects a longing for a world without a
need for hard choices and the sacrifice
these necessarily entail we may well
long to stick to the facts but we
eventually have to try to lead our lives
according to values which are inherently
much more contentious and complicated
structures there is no merely fact-based
road to a good and contented life the
passion against bias often comes to a
head in our thinking about news
organizations in certain circles there's
a particular loathing for what's termed
biased news and a belief in the option
of a decent news organization which is
going to always an inherently be
unbiased unfortunately there is simply
no way of providing and factual unbiased
answers to the really big issues facing
society's news organizations that boast
about their neutrality forget that
neutrality is simply impossible visa vie
they're really urgent questions
confronting our civilization the word
bias ultimately simply alludes to the
business of having a tank on existence
one may have a better or worse take but
one needs attained
one needs eventually to tackle the
question of what's important just and
worth striving for if news or
information or even philosophy are going
to matter to us really matter they will
have to be presented to us by
organizations that have tried to think
through the ends of human life that have
a vision of where we're trying to go as
a species and that if somewhere
articulated their answers to their
audiences the issue is not there for the
illusory and timid one between bias and
fact but between better and worse
varieties of bias we should never knock
to take the most obvious examples
America's Fox News or Britain's Daily
Mail just on the basis that they are
biased we should only ever argue that
they seem badly biased that's the battle
to fight we also need an extension of
our sense of what sort of bias can exist
at present we're used to thinking of
bias simply in terms of right and left
but this is a radical reduction in the
kinds of bias that are theoretically
available to us we don't always have to
limit things to a choice between blue
and red we might discover a bias in
favor of the wisdom of more tamely the
dark consoling pessimism of Schopenhauer
or the wit and humanity of Marcel Proust
we could be biased towards ambiguity
cheerful despair or insane insanity our
societies would be richer if we were
better not as stripping facts of bias
but at developing our capacities for
higher bias all individuals and
organizations even ones like the BBC
Wikipedia or a great university in fact
believe in all sorts of things deep down
they aren't as neutral as they want us
to think
that is an extremely good thing so it's
high time for them to stop hiding behind
a false defense of their factual
impartiality and to come out from behind
the shadows with a clear articulation of
their vision of a good society it's time
for biases to conflict openly as part of
a healthy democratic process we don't
need our information stripped of bias we
need to evolve our way through clash of
ideologies towards the best kinds of
bias furthermore we'll have matured when
we start to know where our own biases
really are and so start to get less
prickly and touchy about the biases of
others thank you for watching remember
to like the video and subscribe to our
channel for more
you